[موسيقى]
هل تفعلين التوقي لحياتنا افضل الى علاقه
غير عادله مع الطبيعه
ارتفع متوسط درجه حراره العالم بمعدلات
غير مسبوقه مقارنه مع ما قبل الثوره
الصناعيه العلماء يحذرون
وتقلبات الجويه خطيره
الحديد حول الانبعاثات الكربونيه باتجديه
والعالم يتباطا في هذه الحلول والا موارد
الكوكب اساس تنتهي الانسان سيتاثر
وبالتالي لان لا نعلم ماذا الاجيال
القادمه سوف تجد
يتفق العالم ربما ان الاحتباس الحراري بات
قريبا من الخروج عن نطاق السيطره ينذر هذا
بكارثه كبيره
والنبي
هل فقدنا السيطره وهل يمكن تفاديين نتائج
نشاطنا على هذا الكوكب اذا مرتفع الدرجه
الحراره بواحد ونصف في المئه خلال العشرين
عاما المقبله فالعواقب كارثيه
لان الموضوع ليس درجه الحراره فقط الموضوع
انه الاحتباس الحراري له دور كبير جدا في
عمليه
الامن الانساني يعني يهدد الامن الانساني
[موسيقى]
نظريا هناك امل لكبح درجات الحراره بشكل
كبير اذا ما تم الالتزامه بالهدف طويل
الامد وبالوصول بالمنبعاثات الكربونيه الى
صفر منتصف القرن الحالي
عمليا نتجه الى ارتفاع درجته الحراره نحو
ثلاث درجات مئويه اذ ان تعهدات دول العالم
غير كافيه لبلوغ الهدف منشور
فيديو
بيبي
الصوره تبدو مختلفه اعلن منتج نفط الاول
في العالم عن خطه يلتزم فيها بصفر
انبعاثات كربونيه عام 2050 في الوقت نفسه
اكدت الرياضه على ان امن الطاقه ومعالجه
مشكلتي التغير المناخي يجب ان يسيرها جنبا
الى جنب
[موسيقى]
ارتباطنا في منطقه الجوف في الاراضي
الزراعيه في منطقه نهاد بالاخص ارتباط
جدري
[موسيقى]
لما نمشي بين اشجار الزيتون هناك نحس انه
واحد من المحيط الاساسي فينا حتى نحس انه
واحد من عائلتنا
الارض هذه زرعوها الاباء والاجداد
ونهتم فيها كثير بيننا وبين ارتباط حس
كثير
[موسيقى]
جايز شاب سعودي اكمل تعليمه عبر برنامج
الابتعاث في استراليا
بعد عودته للجوف حصل جائز على فرصه للعمل
في مشروع من مشاريع الطاقه المتجدده
[موسيقى]
في بلد يوفروا 10% من الانتاج العالمي
للنفط ويستحوذ على 70 في المئه من الطاقه
الانتاجيه الاحتياطيه عالميا شهيدا جائز
مؤخرا حدثا مهما
يجتمع اليوم في هذه القمه لتنسيق الجهود
الى حمايه البيئه
ومواجهه التغيير المناخي بوضع خارطه
الطريق لتقليل انبعاثات الكربونيه في
المنطقه باكثر من 10% من اسهامات العالميه
وزراعه 50 مليار شجره في المنطقه اننا
اليوم بدش الحقبه خضراء جديده
من اثار تغيير مناخي لا تقصر على البيئه
فقط
على الاقتصاد والامن ومع ذلك نحن نعين
التغيير مناخي هو فرصه اقتصاديا الافراد
والقطاع الخاص التي ستحفظ مبادل شرق
الاوسط الاخضر لخلق وظائف نوعيه وتعزيز
الابتكار
تستهدف السعوديه الوصول بحصه الطاقه
المتجدده والغاز لتشكل 50% من احتياجاتها
من الطاقه محليه عام 2030
لماذا في العالم كله وليس على مستوى الشرق
الاوسط المملكه العربيه السعوديه
هي من حققت اول تحالف على ارض الواقع على
مستوى الشرق الاوسط مع الدول التي تشترك
في الالتزام البيئي اثنين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه هي بهذه المبادره عملت ما يسمى
بمنصه راس المال والمعرفه يعني معناته انه
جمعته الاستثمار مع التقنيات لانه عشان
نكافحه البنات لابد ان يكون لدينا تقنيه
لهذا الموضوع ثلاثه المملكه هي من عملت
ما يسمى
اقوى باور شركه سعوديه تعود ملكيه 44 في
المئه منها للدوله عبر صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه
تساهم الشركه في تسريع عمليه التحول في
قطاع الطاقه عالميا باصول تتجاوز 67 مليار
دولار وانتشار فتنه عشر دوله تغير المناخي
اللي احنا اليوم نشهد في العالم كله هي كل
التاثير سلبي كبير على موارد شركه اكوا
بارك الحمد لله منذ عاملات من 2004 الى
اليوم طورت القطاع التحرير جدا جدا كبير
تنتج السعوديه 22 في المئه من الانتاج
العالمي للمياه المحلى يستحوذ هذا الانتاج
على خمسه عشره في المئه من الطلب المحلي
على الطاقه مؤخرا تنبهت الرياض لضروره
تطوير نموذج جديد لتحليه المياه
هذه هي رابغ ثلاثه محطه جديده تنتج
600000 متر مكعب من المياه المحلا يوميا
على الساحل الغربي
[موسيقى]
محطات عمل بتقنيه تناضح العكسي وهي تقنيه
صديقه للبيئه بحيث انه استهلاك الطاقه
الكهربائيه قليل جدا مقارنه بمحطات تحديد
الحراريه التي تستهلك طاقه كهربائيه اعلى
استهلاك الطاقه اقل 75% يعني على سبيل
المثال للحصر انه محطه مشروع رابطه تحقق
ثلاثه كيلو وات ساعه مقارنه بمحطات
التحليل الحراريه اللي حوالي 14 كيلو وات
ساعه فلكان تتخيل يعني الفرق في الحفظ في
الطاقه الكهربائيه وبالتالي حرق الوقود
ولن يكون هناك اي معدات كربونيه من
المشروع
بلغت تكلفه انشاء رابط 3 700 مليون دولار
ضمتها اقوى باور لمحفظتي استثماراتها في
قطاع المياه اذ تنتج الشركه سته ملايين
و700,000 متر مكعب من المياه المحلا يوميا
داخل السعوديه اكبر محطه في العالم وافضل
كفاءه محطه في العالم اليوم تعمل يعني
شركه زي رابط اليوم حق التحليه اليوم
يشغلها 39 هذه كان يشغلها بنفس الطاقه الف
اليوم تتكلم عن تقليل التكلفه اللي كانت
التكلفه حقه الانتاج المتر المكعب كان
بثلاثه اربعه دولار اليوم تتكلم عن اقل من
40 سنه
هذا ليش لانك قللت التكلفه هيكون دول
كثيره في العالم اللي ما كان ممكن تستخدم
التقنيه التحليه اليوم قلدت تكاليفها
بيقدرون العالميه وهذا صار مصدر مستدام
خفضت السعوديه العام الماضي
28, سنويا من الانبعاثات الكربونيه
النتيجه عن تحليه المياه
من المستهدف عام 2030
تدريجيا يتم احلال محطات تحليه المياه
بتقنيه التناضح العكسي مكاني محطات
التحليه الحراريه كما يتم العمل على تطوير
تقنيات لامتصاص الغازات المنبعثه من
المداخل والاستفاده منها اختيار التصميم
في شركه رابطه الثالثه كان اختيار فريد
ومميز بحيث تترابط جميع وحدات الانتاج
والاستفاده من الطاقه الكامله في الرجيع
وكذلك انه نسبه الاستخلاص العاليه من مياه
البحر مقارنه بالتقنيه توضح العكسي الاخرى
التي يكون فيها نسبه الاستخلاص اقل من ما
هو موجود في شركه الرابط كارقام يعطيك
عقيل انه الان احنا 40% نسبه استخلاص
للمياه البحر لانها في المحطات التراضح
العكسيه الثانيه تقريبا نسبه الاستخلاص
تصل الى 35%
تحد هذه الكفاءه من الاثار المضره بالبيئه
البحريه المحيطه تحديدا في معالجه المياه
الرجعه وبالتالي لم يتاثر نشاط الصيادين
على الساحلي بشكل جوهري
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
روح يا محمد فك الغلطه ذاك اللي فوق وتلقى
الطلاب طلعوني
ليه في الصيد 40 سنه
قبل 40 سنه ما في تصاريح ما في اي حاجه
تطلع
وكان مرسال البقيله
بعد جاءت جاءت ارامكو
حولونا للثلج بعد
[موسيقى]
المنشات الحكوميه تحولنا الى القرار هنا
الان تطلع ثلاث ايام يومين
معاذ الصيد يوم واحد
في الايام السابقه
[موسيقى]
لكن الزمن الاول ليش موجود كثير ما في
استهلاك كثير
الصياد يمشي على
رجله ويشيل السمك
[موسيقى]
انا شايف حفيدك طالع معاك اليوم تاخذه
معاك على طول في في طلعات الصيد
انا اعلمه زي هذا اعلمه
لوزاره المهنه تعلم السباحه اولا يتعلم
الغوص يتعلم
دخول البحر
[موسيقى]
تتنازع تنميه الصناعيه عاده مع اهداف
المحافظه على البيئه الا ان العالم بدا
يسون ضوابط جديده قد تحد من الاضرار
بالطبيحه
[موسيقى]
ومنذ بدايه نشاطها في رابغ كان لاكوا باور
دور المجتمعي اخر بانشاء المعهد العالي
التقنيات المياه والكهرباء
[موسيقى]
حامد كانت له فرصه في المعهد
طبعا الحمد لله انا بعد ما انتهيت مرحله
البكالوريوس في الجامعه طبعا حاولت التحكم
سوق العمل حاولت ادورلي على وظيفه يعني
مناسبه لتخصصي بحكم اني متخرج بامتياز قال
الفرص كبيره قدامك بس للاسف السوق طلع فيك
اتفاق يعني ما في اي وظائف جديده للسوق
حاولت تلحقته كذا شريكه ما كانت صراحه
للامانه زي ما انا متخيل يعني
بعد كده تقديم على المعهد وكان من ضمن
التخصصات المطروحه الطاقه المتجدده تقدمت
عليه الحمد لله
فالمجاني القبول وقعت عقد معه شركه هي
شركه هوبر
يغذي المعهد مشاريع الطاقه وتحليه المياه
في السعوديه تخرج من هذا المعهد اكثر من
سته الاف طالب حتى اليوم
بالاضافه للدبلوم يقدم المعهد برامج
ودورات تدريبيه منها ما تم تصميمه لخريجي
البكالوريوس الذين لم يتمكنوا من الحصول
على فرص عمل مناسبه بهدف اعاده توجيههم
لدخول قطاع الطاقه المتجدده
[موسيقى]
المعهد عندنا انه
نخصص برامجنا على حسب احتياجات سوق العمل
بالتعاون مع شركاء
بيننا وبين الشركات المتخصصه في الطاقه
المتجدده تعاون في بناء هذه المناهج ومن
ثم نرسلها الى المؤسسه العامه للتدريب
المهني للحصول
ولا تقتصر برامج المعهد على الطلاب فقط
حيث اطلق المعهد برنامجا لسلامه الصناعيه
وهو موجه للطالبات
متوفره الامكانياتكم في جامعه لسه ناشئه
في رابه فما كان في الامكانيات اللي ندخل
فيها تطبيق العملي بس لما درست في المعهد
يعني درسنا 10 اسابيع مكثفه وفي تطبيق
عملي يعني كان في ارض الواقع حقيقي يعني
بطبقنا كل المعلومات اللي اخذناها على ارض
الواقع عشان كده حسين يعني خلاص
يعني صرنا قادرين ومؤهلين انه ندخل سوق
العمل احنا بنكمل العزيزيه ما شاء الله
اكوا باور المعهد اهميه كبيره وسطى فتره
تحول تعيشها السعوديه لتنويع مصادر الطاقه
في المملكه الحمد الله صار عندنا قدرات
وامكانيات وانتم عارفين كل هذه اللي احنا
شايفينها الحين اللي جاي الان اللي احنا
فيه واللي جاي ان شاء الله في المستقبل
كلهم برامج الرؤيه وهذه رؤيه 2030
واليوم الطاقه تحدي الكثير من الدول
العالم
وايضا تحدي لتحويل الطاقه من الطاقه
اعتياديه الى طاقه الخضراء ولكن ايضا
الحمد لله فرص كبيره لنا في المملكه لان
احنا عندنا القدرات والامكانيات وعندنا
المصادر المحليه اللي احنا ان شاء الله
نسويها
وتعتقل شركه انا دورها في ايجاد الفرصي
للشباب هو دور اجتماعي تلعبه الشركه في
المنطقه
من يوم ما ابتدينا المعهد كان فكره انه
نركز على اهم محتوى وهو الانسان
ينتظر حامد يوم التخرج يتذكره قريته ويفكر
كيف سوف يسهم في تنميتها
طبعا عندنا المزارع في القريه تقريبا
ما عندها مصدر كهرباء خطوط الكهرباء
انا اقدر اصنع منه نظام ما يسمونه
الافريقيه النظام مستقل ركب دي في عندي في
المزرعه اغذي الاحمال عندي طول اليوم يصير
يعني خلاص الكهرباء
في شخص جدا طموح وشخص يعني انا اخذ منه
يعني الهامه
هو خالد طبعا فكان يقول لي دائما اذا انت
ان شاء الله صرت طاقه متجدده اول بيت تركب
فيه هو البيت تبعي ذي الكلمه لسه لحد الان
تظرفه يعني ان شاء الله لحد ما اخلص
يشكل التوجه السعودي نحو مصادر الطاقه
المتجدده نقطه تحول جديده في طريقه حياه
مواطن اكبر منتج للنفط في العالم وعلى
الرغم من الجدل الذي دار خارجيا حول جديه
هذه المشاريع تختو الرياض بثبات ضمن
برنامجها الوطني للطاقه المتجدده
[موسيقى]
في عام 2019 عدلت الرياض من حصتها
المستهدفه لانتاج الطاقه الشمسيه لتبلغ 20
جيجا واط في
2023 و 40 جيجا واط في 2030 مقارنه مع
انتاج متواضع عند اثنين ميجا وات في 2010
مشروع سكاكا كان اول مشاريع الطاقه
الشمسيه الضخمه ضمن البرنامج الوطني
للطاقه المتجدده خلقه هذا المشروع بلا شك
قيمه مضافه لسكان الجوف شمالي السعوديه
[موسيقى]
تتيح للشباب الوظائف بمنطقتهم وعندها لهم
وثاني شيء مصدر رزق بدل ما الواحد يروح
مثلا للرياض والله والجده ولا الجنوب ولا
يكون عمله قريبه من اهله
كثير بحيث انه الواحد ااا وجد في المنطقه
اللي هو متربي فيها وهمم وترعرع فيها همم
الوظائف والاماكن اللي في شغفها انه يعمل
فيها
تبلغ سعه مشروع سكاكا 300 ميجا واط ويتكون
من مليون و 200 الف لوح شمسي تمتد على سته
كيلومترات بتكلفه تتجاوز 300 مليون دولار
وفازت اقوى باور بعقد المشروع بعد تقديمها
سعرا قياسيا للتعرفه
الشركه كان لها برنامج لتدريب وتاهيل
الشباب من بدايه المشروع الين ما اكتمل
وانتهى انشاء المشروع الحمد لله اليوم
اتكلم معك بعد سنتين من تشغيل المشروع
المشروع يشغل ويصور فريق سعودي كامل 100%
وبعد اطلاقه مشروع سكاكا اعلنت السعوديه
عن سبعه مشاريع جديده للطاقه الشمسيه في
مناطقه مختلفه هذه المشاريع ستموت اكثر من
600,000 منزل بالكهرباء بطاقه انتاجيه
تتجاوز ثلاثه الاف و600 ميجا جواد
في الصلاه
فيديوهات فيديوهات
[موسيقى]
متجدده يبدو ان السعوديه
البحر الاحمر اللي هو اكبر مشروع سياحي في
العالم عشان اكبر مشروع ترفيه في العالم
اكبر مشروع في جوده حياه في العالم ان
يكون بالطاقه الخضراء طاقه شمسيه ولكن
ايضا اكبر مشروع تخزين للطاقه في العالم
اليوم جوده الحياه في المملكه هي اساس من
برامج الرؤيه ومن اهم الاشياء في جوده
الحياه اللي هم موضوع المناخ موضوع التلوث
وموضوع جوده الحياه جزء منها مهم عشان كذا
المملكه تعمل ليست عشان الخارج تعمل عشان
الداخل وعندها مبدا وعندها اييي يعني
استراتيجيه باذن الله تكون عامل محفزه
للعالم كله
يشكلوا مشاريع الطاقه المتجدده جزءا من
التزام اكبر تحريسه عليه الرياض التي
اطلقت مؤخرا مبادره السعوديه الخضراء
ورصدت لها 700 مليار ريال واعلنت عن 60
مشروعا ضمن هذه المبادره حتى تحقيق الوعد
الاخضر وبلوغ هدف الحياد الصفري في 2060
تصدق وانا اصور هاليومين في مشاريع الطاقه
المتجدده اتذكر الصور اللي كنت اشوفها حق
الناس اللي طلعوا البترول صوركم تروحوا
تكون نفس الشيء يمكن بالعشرين سنه 30 سنه